all right so this is the voice in the
night this is the episode where Cora she
joins sort of this task force to take
down B sequel as people and try to find
this amount guy you know a stop here
because the city is terrified of this
guy now they don't know what's gonna
happen
and she initially doesn't want to but
then sort of gets coaxed into it and
rushes into a thinking that she can
overcome her fear by just confronting it
head on without thinking too much about
it and sure enough it almost gets her to
lose everything you know she comes out
all right but they're sort of this
threat that you know she will be like
the ultimate like in the-- great victory
death but what all of this is over which
is not very encouraging and she realizes
she should have confronted her fears a
more logical way like talking about and
so on so forth so one pattern I'm
starting to notice with this show is
that I mean which is fine for one or two
episodes but it's like I don't know it's
starting to become this steady pattern
is Korra's going to rush into something
without thinking about it realize she
made a mistake and you know acknowledge
it at the end
essentially sir the old school Sandra
Bullock Julia Roberts movie formula and
I hate it in those movies and it's
starting to get to me here a little bit
I don't know if they're gonna do
variations on that or if they're gonna
mix it up a bit which they're they're
not bad lessons that they're teaching
again and the way that they're using
Cora in many respects is very clever
because I'm seeing the stuff I'm seeing
how she's reacting to this and again sir
connecting it back to serve our
generation and the generation right
after us this is something that occurs a
lot I mean the scene where she's invited
to a party it's supposed to be this big
social get-together and of course the
was of the tarrlok guy I like this guy
by the way he's a good sort of you know
sneaky
we'll pay in the ass like that I like
that guy oh but that they he puts in
front of all these reporters and they're
asking all these questions you know are
you running away why is this more
important why is this more important and
she doesn't know how to confront these
questions or these feelings they're
suddenly being thrown at her because
they're so new so she instead doesn't
want to think of herself as being afraid
or a coward even though she's feeling
this great fear so she just rushes into
it and she feels the more forward and
the more she can take something on the
better she'll be able to fight it off
which is sometimes the case but and not
always there again it's about that
balance um and the and the mentor comes
and says maybe it's best to talk about
it and she chooses not to you know she's
afraid to acknowledge her her weakness
and her fears and at the very end she
realizes that she should have and it's
it's effective at the end like it's for
me it holds up okay because the endings
are always so nicely done and they're so
good at summing up what the problem was
and what they should have done with it
but it's it's the lead-in and maybe
maybe it is because they feel a little
rushed at times it's a huge part of it
because if it really took like if this
took like maybe two episodes or
something that to really sort of dive
into sort of the fears she's feeling
which it's not that it doesn't at all
it's that I think you really need to
understand what she's going through a
leg when she calls out aman and says
let's sell this right now you and me
blah blah blah that seemed very much out
of nowhere and I think if you had time
to really search her like even though
she's helping tarrlok fight these people
maybe she's still having the bad dreams
or maybe she's still having this fear or
maybe it's you see it's keeping her up
at night and that's not working so she
decides to try this you know that little
bit of time it does add up and you
avatar was usually pretty good at
balancing that out is sometimes there
would be a little rushed here and there
but I mean
you'll get Zuko and how great that
character is developed and how much time
they took to develop him so I heard
their stuff about like how they didn't
really have time to develop this or they
didn't or not not time develop it uh
time to get more episodes out of it
because I guess it's 12 and whether or
not they didn't know if it's gonna be
one season or not if that is the case it
kind of shows um you know I would like a
little bit more sort of just more time
on these I think that's really it I
don't mind that she does this stuff I
think there just needs to be a little
bit more time explaining or showing the
process of how she sort of worked in
this way you don't reminds me of mayor
that episode of it's like the one
episode I didn't like in Avatar that was
the Bato of the Water Tribe one where
Aang is suddenly doing all this stuff
where it's like where did this come from
like this does not see my game it's like
oh he's a kid I'm like but that's it's
just not his character and if they
really delve into showing much more time
if they put a lot more time into showing
how this could happen it could be
explained but because it was so rushed
and just thrown in there really fast and
it's like just a couple of lines it
didn't come off as very effective so I'm
starting to get a little bit of that
vibe here like I said serve the endings
save it because I think they do they are
very emotional and they and they come to
grips with this stuff but I don't know
it just feels a little rushed to me but
I guess a lot of saying before I'm sorry
I got a little sidetracked there I
imagined but I was talking about sir
like with our generation and so the
Millennials - is that whenever sort of
confronted with sort of did especially
online when you're hoping just to have a
normal conversation or chatroom or
something like that and think you're
just suddenly attacked or someone wants
to threaten you whether it be a troll or
someone that just has a different
opinion it just really wants to come
Frank you're just someone really
emotional whatever you don't always know
how to take it and there's of course a
lot of famous conversations on blogs are
for
or whatever of either just people
getting really emotional or even more
famous people getting really emotional
and just totally attacking and it's
because they don't know what to do they
just this is something very new to them
so I think like I said the stuff she's
going through and sir the issues they're
attacking me in any art time period I
would sort of go I don't know it seems a
little circle a shade or whatever but I
I guess I see more of it nowadays of
people just feeling a lot of emotion and
not knowing what to do with it and
because the social media has allowed us
to act on our emotions without even
thinking about it that's exactly what we
do we react without even thinking about
and we're not always the guidance now
does not come from people giving advice
or anything it comes from our mistakes
which in many ways is not always bad but
in many other ways if you don't catch
those mistakes you can keep making
mistakes and they can get worse and
worse so I'm not against what they're
trying to get across with this character
I'm not against her being like a
blowhard and you know really proud of
everything and but insecure as well
because they have her learning the
lessons and I think it does connect a
lot to again sir this rise in technology
I mean for us it's the social media and
here it's just the rise of media I guess
I mean the fact that there is a media
now right down to every episode starting
off with that announcer which I love by
the way I love that they're doing that
yeah last time I lecture the karak all
right has a new threat from the Ben
barrows and Brides like I love them I
love that kind of voice so every time it
starts off like that I love that but I
get it what what I would like to see is
is more time dedicated to these because
as of now like I said they just seem a
touch rushed so yeah that's about it for
this one I mean nothing too much else I
like this tarrlok guy I like this this
villain is a Monde guy but I was at
looks like there's some some romance
going on with the macho character and
the daughter of mr. Ford essentially I
mean that that's I Henry Ford so they're
obviously trying to make that guy be but
yeah so and I sort of like this being
pulled in different directions too with
the you know I on the one hand she sir
wants to focus on the bending on the
other hand now she's in this Pro bending
tournament and on the other hand she's
also in this tack for a test for a thing
now that's trying to take down these bad
people so it's I like she's sort of
being pulled everywhere and that's again
that's a big heavyweight you know on
someone that's said to be you know they
have so many great expectations
essentially so yeah so I still like it I
hope some of the more episodes have a
little bit more time dedicated to this
but again it's only only 12 I mean
that's that's that's tricky for
especially for you know coming off with
something like avatar which did this so
well so yeah we'll just see where it
goes from there that's about it take
care